this week conflict zone is in Berlin
where we caught up with one of West
Africa's most influential leaders he's
John Muhammad President of Ghana lauded
by the West for maintaining a stable
democracy in an otherwise volatile
region but when you look at the fact is
that reputation really justified
president john Mahama favor warm welcome
to conflict zone thank you to let me
start with human rights a subject that
you've drawn attention to many times in
the past July last year at an African
summit you and other leaders unanimously
voted yourselves immunity from
prosecution at a new African court of
justice and human rights due to be set
up in the future why did you take what
Amnesty International called a backward
step in the fight against impunity well
I think that it was a matter that was
quite well debated in there in the
summit and Ghana as a country is a
signature to the Rome Statute and so we
support the work of the International
Criminal Court yes well this went right
against the ICC didn't it was in the
particular case of Qing er in a
situation where an election had been
held and people had been elected by the
people by the electorate and so they had
gotten an endorsement by the electorate
to govern and so we had a strange
situation where the people had given a
Monday to this is in Kenya yang Kenya to
hooroo Andrew total rule and at the same
time ICC said no we need you because we
want to prosecute you for crimes against
humanity and that created you know quite
quite quite a problem but the amendment
that you passed bars the court from
prosecuting sitting African leaders and
senior officials so it's a carte blanche
for the VIP to do all the murdering and
torturing that they want to do you put
yourself above the law no not really I I
believe really it's it's in black and
white I believe that if people are
guilty of crimes against humanity they
must be prosecuted whether they're
sitting leaders or not know if they are
citizen leaders it depends on the
circumstances this is a situation in
which posts what they were accused of
the country had gone to elections and
elected these people as the leaders and
the criminal court wanted to try them
and that
was what created the difficulties we
have for VIPs for sitting leaders and
senior officials in the future
you weren't passing judgment on one
event in Kenya Kenya was the situation
that created what what the African Union
sub it's discussed of course there had
been the case of Omar Bashir against
whom a warrant has been served and many
times the court has tried to arrest him
and and try him but even before that the
South Africa failed to execute the world
yeah because the African Union had
granted immunity because of the
conference you can have leaders coming
to discuss in a summit and a court you
know chasing leaders with you know I
mean the I guess of the South African
state party to the ICC and pick and
choose which one is a continental body
and if it is holding a summit in your
country it needs a setting immunity to
accede to allow people to come in and
have a discussion
you don't go arresting them when they
have come under auspices of the African
Union that that that was not you are who
I required to comply with the rulings of
the ICC whether that person is given
immunity locally or not you are required
fatto been sudha the icc chief
prosecutor says the South Africans well
in breach of their binding international
commitments there's a disagreement there
between the African Union and the ICC
these are two recognized international
organizations you cannot take the ICC's
opinion over the African Union but I do
believe in justice the ICC is useful and
several African leaders useful for show
you can choose your commitments chaste
alliance there just recently
hissing huh Bree has started to be tried
in Senegal and so there are examples
where people have been brought to
justice and I think that the ICC is
still relevant and is still important in
terms of investigating and prosecuting
cases of crimes against humanity the
commitments are just things to respect
when you like them and you dump them
when you don't you need to weigh the
ICC's you know warrants against the
decision of a people the whole of Kenya
voted these people into office
these are binding international as for -
that you signed up that's far too
against the whole of the King and people
but all the cases where either
self-referred or referred by the
Security Council with African support
three of the cases now under
investigation was self referred to were
referred by the Security Council with
African support yeah that's right okay
so what's the so what's the complaint
about the ICC well Africa has made its
concerns known to the international
community and to the ICC wouldn't it be
more honest to withdraw from the ICC I
don't think she serves a purpose I think
we that's why we have members of the
Rome Statute and I think the ICC has a
relevance but I guess that what should
happen is we must stick onboard the
concerns of Africa Africa feels targeted
rightly or wrongly it's like only
African leaders are being arraigned
before the ICC and so Africa feels
support with Africa
fantastic but some concerns have been
have been raised by the African Union
and I think that the United Nations the
International Court of Justice and the a
you should dialogue and find out how
they take onboard the concerns raised by
Africa you were asked this year when you
visited the Gambia to raise the issue of
the appalling human rights record there
why didn't you when you were in The
Gambia
I was in The Gambia to participate in
the 50th anniversary celebration
and I went as head of the echo s and
that was the simple reason for which I
went there the copy Human Rights
initiative Amnesty International Media
Foundation for West Africa all asked you
to raise the case of Human Rights which
has been under attack for many years I
did not have any official role and so I
didn't speak in any forum I was just a
guest of course I had private
discussions with President yeah Jimmy
but did you raise what is the
International said when it said freedom
remains an illusion for most Gambians
particularly journalists and human
rights activists within fear of
arbitrary arrest torture incommunicado
detention unfair trials rape you didn't
raise any of everyone be unfair on my
parts to disclose a private conversation
with another African leader I don't
think you don't care about these things
I care about them but not enough to
speak out in public about you don't know
if I spoke about them but I say it's
unfair for me to disclose what we spoke
about present mama your government is
often touted as the most stable
democracy in West Africa the commitment
to transparency and accountable
government
I have ghanians been waiting 10 years to
get a right to information law a legal
right to access information why is it
taking so long I don't think that it
changes the sense of free expression and
the very vibrant media landscape that's
Ghana has it's taking unduly long I
agree with you and my government is fast
tracking it as quickly as possible
indeed the government of President Artem
else is there of which our vice
president as the government that
submitted it finally to Parliament for
approval before then it had gone through
varying processes of consultation and so
it's been with Parliament unduly long
the life of that Parliament expired and
so this Parliament has taking it up and
I believe that before this Parliament
right
the right to information bill will be
passed but let me see some 80 NGOs have
criticized the draft they say it's too
app a kit Sun transparent there's a lack
of independent oversight and the broad
exemptions on information risk making
this toothless indeed that is that is
what has delayed it there's not been
consensus on what the scope of
exemptions should be and so it's gone
back and forth I believe that people
price satisfied with what we have it's a
starting point and if we need to tweak
it a bit in the future we can always
make an amendment to the act but let me
say that in Ghana
there are many guarantees of free speech
and an independent media one of the best
is chapter 12 of our constitution that
guarantees a free and independent media
so you've nothing to hide I don't I
don't think that the right to
information bill would transform Ghana's
independent media and landscape in in a
dramatic manner we have that freedom of
ready our people have absolutely no
problem expressing themselves in the
media the media has the freedom to
investigate anything at once and so the
freedom of information bill will only
enhance freedoms that they have already
and so we we hope it will be passed well
it means a lot to 80 NGOs who've been
campaigning for the last 10 years
yes it's they've been campaigning and
it's going through the process I'm sure
Parliament to pass it before the life of
this Parliament is over and when that is
then the media and researchers and
anybody who wants to take advantage of
it can do so when you took over in Ghana
you promised to build a strong and
resilient economy instead you presided
over steadily worsening economy growth
has slowed dramatically it's down from
9% 2011 it's expected to be 3.9 percent
this year according to the OECD last
July Ghana's Trade Union Congress held a
nationwide demonstration issued you an
ultimatum address the widespread
perceived corruption in the country and
hoped the depreciation of the currency
why isn't that happening the economy is
not like
a motor vehicle where you just tighten
nuts and bolts and the engine is there's
efficient running of it or inefficient
running you you cannot attribute it to
inefficiency there are issues that
resulted in the current economic
challenges that we face and I just walk
you through one is the implementation of
a new Universal salary instruction in
which we were trying to achieve equity
in public service salaries and wages in
its implementation
there was a wage overrun and the wage
bill ballooned you know much higher than
was anticipated so that's what that was
one of the causes aside but investors
are losing confidence know no investor
confidence aside Association of Ghana
industry says business confidence
dropped from 98 points at the end of
last year to 85 in the first quarter of
this year that's a loss of 13 points in
business confidence business confidence
is still high I'm just going to explain
to you
we have economies that have
traditionally been based on the export
of primary products an import of capital
goods it takes time to diversify those
economies and so economies are
susceptible to the shocks on the
international commodity markets remember
that cocoa is a leading export and then
gold is a second leading export we've
just had an oil and gas industry a new
oil and gas industry now what happened
between 2010 and 2012 was that there was
a dramatic reduction in price of cocoa
Gold has still not recovered from above
2000 dollars gold is selling uh Center
for Policy Analysis says we Guardians
are giving too many excuses and blaming
our problems on the negative impact of
external forces investors don't trust
the way we're managing the economy
that's your own Center for Policy
Analysis you can you can pick up many
such studies what I'm saying is they're
all saying the same thing we need we
need to change the basis of our economy
it doesn't take two years to do it I've
been in office for two and a half years
it doesn't take two and a half years
to change transform as at the basis of
the economy and that's why we have
presented to Parliament an agenda for
transformation to diversify the economy
to add value addition and not just
export primary products to introduce
manufacturing to expand the services
sector people always in the majority of
your people don't approve of your
handling of the economy majority of
people in all countries are impatient
even here in Europe in the developed
world in Europe people are patient
everybody is in 56 percent of
respondents believe the current
government is managing the economy very
badly now that has knock-on effects for
your elections next year doesn't it well
I'm not denying the economic challenges
we have been through but the turnaround
is happening and if you look at the
reports that we're getting currently
from the consolidation fiscal
consolidation is beginning to take place
the currency is stabilizing we're going
to see inflation inflation is slowing
actually the rate of rise of inflation
is slowing and so that turnaround is
happening people are being laid off
because of the energy crisis because
there is insufficient electricity your
Chamber of Commerce and Industry warned
in April that 5,000 jobs could be lost
by September if the power wasn't fixed
you said I will fix this energy
challenge you made that promise in
February I mean the promise that I'll
fix the challenge in the State of the
Nation Address in February and I gave a
deadline of the end of this year our
economy has been growing at a phenomenal
pace average over the last decade 7%
it's led to an increase demand for
electric power demand for electric power
is rising at between 10 and 12 percent
per annum Bob is there no planning for
that you're talking you're asking about
my administration and I'm saying that
these are cumulative these things didn't
happen overnight and so when I say I'll
fix it we are bringing in emergency
power thousand megawatts of emergency
power in the next few months to be able
to catch up with demand these are the
bodies yes the budgets from Turkey
then we're planning another 4,000
megawatts of power over the next five
years between now and 2020 and so you
cannot blame the shortage of power on
one single government or the present it
is cumulative
we had Akosombo dam for which we thought
we would have power forever but
increasingly Ghana is growing average
economic growth rate about 7% over the
last decade and so the demand for power
is growing how worried are you that
corruption massive corruption continues
to drain the public finances in Ghana
because this is a huge concern among
people in your country corruption in
economy your own Auditor General
revealed that in the last year 1.7
million dollars which had been earmarked
to bring power to local communities have
been spent on 38 luxury cars how could
this happen it's it's it's supposed to
have been a program that was financed by
the US XM and as part of the program
there was provision for vehicles for
monitoring and evaluation for the for
project vehicles and so those vehicles
were supplied as part of the project and
the Auditor General didn't approve this
transaction he said there was no
permission for it wasn't it it was
approached it was a project that had
began from the previous government which
was inherited by this government and so
at a time this government came into
place it was in its implementation or
face you think it's okay to spend 1.7
million not luxury cars the question was
about the kind of cars that were
purchased
I believe that project cars should be
probably four by fours rugged in enough
to be able to go into the countryside
but these decisions had been taking elia
before I came into government and so
there are things for which we continue
to investigate and punish people if they
are found guilty of haven't done
anything I think we need I wonder how
much punishment there is because the
anti-corruption coalition said in April
that despite the Chief Justice setting
up a financial tribunal two years ago
to prosecute public officials for
misappropriating money not a single case
had so far been heard so how much is
there really a fight against corruption
going on there not a single case er the
focus of the fight against corruption is
to strengthen the institutions in order
to prevent people from having the
opportunity to engage in corruption and
so we're doing a reform of the financial
administration system and introduced in
the giftmas which is a new electronics
budget management platform and that
would make it more difficult for people
to indulge in corruption the Institute
of Economic Affairs in some sections the
public sector a culture of impunity to
embezzle has taken a grip is that true
the Auditor General presents his report
to Parliament every year Parliament
holds a public setting and invites the
agencies that are cited in the Auditor
General's report for misuse of public
funds there is supposed to be an
agreement between the Chief Justice and
Parliament this is between the judiciary
and the legislature on how peasants
found culpable in that report are
supposed to be handled I am for
expediting prosecution of these people
and I've told the Attorney General who
was the Minister of Justice to do
everything in her power to ensure that
people who are found to have
deliberately misused government friends
are punished but there's a system that
has to be followed we're no longer in
the period where you arrested people and
then you went looking for the evidence
before you prosecuted you prosecute them
you need to go through the process of
producing the dark heads put them
putting them before but it's not taking
place at the moment it's happening it's
happening I know that no not to people's
satisfaction people accuse you of paying
lip service to reform there was a
headline November 2013 in the Ghana web
which said simply looting galore
auditor-general weeps for Ghana if you
if you take those reports on an
anecdotal and circumstantial
you know mana you would in the you would
come to the conclusion that there is an
increase in corruption this government
is committed to the fight against
corruption and that's why we are
committed to exposing and sanctioning
corrupts officials as I speak as I speak
people are facing trial for various acts
of corruption there is a case of GIDA
where we have a former public officials
you know facing the courts there's the
case of deliberating session of ghost
names on the national service payroll we
have more than hundred officials from
the National Service Scheme who have
faced in different forms of sanctions
and so as and when these things are
brought to attention government action
demin have set up two other
investigative agencies that they don't
need to wait for my approval to do what
they have to do if they find corruption
dig' investigated if people are culpable
they should punish them are you also
committed to doing something about the
critical sectors of Ghana's economy such
as mining agricultural and fishing
sectors who use the worst forms of child
labor are you still trying to do
something about that because a Special
Rapporteur on contemporary forms of
slavery visited Ghana a couple of years
ago and gave a very depressing picture
of slavery of sexual exploitation of
children as young as three being forced
to work in order to provide some care
for them or their parents how can that
go on sometimes you have to walk through
these reports and do a careful analysis
of these reports I mean how can a child
three years old be forced to work I mean
what kind of productivity can you get
from a three-year-old child in some
cases there are cases of social
acculturation but even if it was a
seven-year-old or any no no no I know I
know but I'm saying that if you just
take these reports on the face value you
might come to conclusions that are not
right our government is concerned about
child labor we have a Ministry of gender
and children that is 24/7 looking at
issues of child labor and I'm saying
that if you rely on some of these
reports that are issued on Africa some
of them
I'm misleading why would a two-year-old
child before strike or serving your
child what happens is in some cases is
social acculturation families are
involved in some form of work they don't
leave they don't have a way of leaving
the children at home and so they go to
the farm with the child as that parents
are working the child gets involved in
doing something like that criticism was
that you applied insufficient funds to
do something about this very serious
issue
no no Minister on gender and children is
working not only with budgetary funds
but also in collaboration with
international organizations like UNICEF
so you would consist this report now
adequate measures it says they've been
taken due to insufficient funds you
would contest we we have been working
for instance in the cocoa industry we've
been working with the International
Commission to make sure that children
are not used in in cocoa farms and while
making sure that children must go to
school rather than accompany their
parents 2121 oh one of the fools that
they say are one crowd exploiting
children sexually 120 one of the reasons
one of the reasons why parents carry
their children along when they and they
engage in what about occupations they
are engaged in is because they do not
have daycare centers because they were
not enrolling the children in school
today
okay sexual exploitation but today more
than 90 percent of children who should
be in school
iron school that was not the case before
we have daycare centers where mothers
can be registered and the sexual
exploitation sexual export exploitation
and trafficking is not peculiar to Ghana
after you say it was peculiar but it was
it was underlined as being a major major
problem it is a major problem for us and
it's a major problem that we're dealing
with children leave their families and
get engaged in the cities and sex trade
it happens in the world it's something
of concern in the developed world
this human trafficking and sex trade in
the developed world it's meant to fight
it yes and that's why we need money to
fight what we're doing
as we are going in there we're
identifying these young girls most of
the cases what makes them go into this
trade is they do not have skills to
enter the world of work and so they are
lured into the sex trade and so what you
need to do is to identify them
rehabilitate them for those who can go
back to school put them back in school
and for those who do not want to go to
school put them in a skills vocational
training so that when they come back
they have some alternative skills with
which to work rather than go into the
sex trade and so it's a battle we need
to continue fighting and the fact that
one report is produced and says that yes
you found young people in the sex trade
means that government is condoning it no
government is not condoning it
government is doing everything possible
to make sure that we create a life of
dignity and prosperity for our people I
understand JAMA Hama
thanks very much for being on conflict
so thank you